today is national beer candy and rocky
is live at craft house to see how they
are celebrating hey rocky
hey you too yet okay so first things
first i want to make this very clear
national beer can appreciation day is
not just you know slamming beer cans on
the forehead that would be the complete
opposite it is about appreciating
this the artistry behind the beer can
right dave absolutely thanks for being
here today rock well thank you today i
get to make or can my very first beer
and i'm very excited to be here at this
local brewery tell everybody about craft
house before we start absolutely uh
hello everyone my name is dave i'm
co-owner of craft health spuri along
with my wife we just celebrated seven
years in the fall
so we're really really excited and we're
keeping things rolling with fantastic
beer so rocky let's get you can and some
beer all right and he has the mic
because he's my coach today all right
let's do it
so go ahead put your can underneath the
tab okay put it on a 45 degree angle
okay and then pull the handle back and
the beer will start to flow look at that
it's coming out there we go start to
come up now what kind of area is coming
out right now this is silver state it's
a blonde nail okay and once you start to
see the foam you're going to see tip it
back up great okay
no it's perfect you're doing great
you're doing great put the lid on top
okay squish it down give it a nice rinse
with water so you get all that beer out
of there
keep the lid just there you go hold that
there perfect it's a whole product
process bring it on over to the canning
machine okay set it in right nice now
what is this beautiful artwork who did
this um this is actually a local artist
uh donovan fitzgerald is his name he's a
local artist yeah lift that up okay and
then you're gonna turn on so we
commissioned him to
create this beautiful piece of artwork
at our arts district location we're
going to turn it on that's here at craft
house you guys have a lot of local
artists create your beer cans yeah it's
really really important for us to
support the community and support the
art scene for sure absolutely now what
you can do is grab the number one and
pull it all the way in okay and it'll
start to crimp the can
yep that's it you're doing great flip it
back okay and then grab number two bring
it on in
spin that back okay turn it off okay
pull the handle down and grab your beer
and you just did it
i feel like the next thing you do is you
open it right absolutely go for it rocky
you gotta hear this
oh yeah happy national beer can
appreciation day here at craft house
coming up let's head into the actual
brewery and see how this works yeah put
you to work
you cracked it open now you gotta drink
it
there you go